[Musique]
avec wohlen phrase bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline à la une de la
presse la contre-offensive de l'armée ou
de crédit ukrainienne donc au nord et à
l'est du pays et la reprise de ville
stratégique 10 young et de coopi on skie
à l'armée russe à l'ukraine oblige la
russie à battre en retraite annoncé ce
matin le tages anzeiger avec une image
du drapeau ukrainien qui flotte de
nouveau devant un bâtiment officiel à
bas la clia ça se trouve dans la région
de kharkiv libération le quotidien
français fait état de la percée des
troupes l'ukrainienne et de la façon
dont moscou cherche à présenter ce recul
comme un simple repli tactique
le quotidien évoque un tournant dans la
guerre menée par vladimir poutine tout
en prévenant qu'il est évidemment trop
tôt pour crier victoire d'après la croix
la contre la contre offensive et
craignent haine n'est probablement qu'un
épisode d'une guerre qui s'annonce très
longue mais l'implication grandissante
des états unis changent rac assurément
la donne
le quotidien chrétien souligne également
le rôle de la france où le soutien à
l'ukraine va aussi se jouer au niveau de
l'opinion cet hiver lorsque la dimension
énergétique de la guerre pèsera sur les
approvisionnements en gaz et bien sûr le
niveau de l'inflation la france hélène
qui demande à la russie de retirer ses
armes de la centrale nucléaire dans un
entretien téléphonique avec l'élysée
hier vladimir poutine a répondu à cette
requête en mettant en garde je le cite
contre les conséquences catastrophiques
des attaques attribuées à l'ukraine
contre l'installation plus généralement
la stratégie du patron du kremlin est
scrutée avec inquiétude par le wall
street journal le quotidien américain
assurant que les dirigeants occidentaux
doivent être préparés à ce que vladimir
poutine ce président jugé capable de
tout utilisent des armes nucléaires ou
tentent d'impliquer directement le temps
dans ce conflit vladimir poutine qu'on
retrouve dans le dessein de moto ne m'en
donne pour le times s'apprêtant à
recevoir ses généraux venu lui annoncer
le retrait tactique des troupes russes
en ukraine les hauts gradés qui se
terrent littéralement on le voit sous
cette table un terminal le de vladimir
poutine au kremlin retrait tactique
étant à l'expression officielle
effectivement pour ne pas dire autre
chose à la une également hélène on en
parlait dans le journal cette attente de
trois jours qui commence en suède où les
résultats des législatives d'hier sont
trop serré pour qu'un vainqueur soit
déjà désignée le les cieux doit devront
en effet patienter au moins jusqu'à
mercredi pour savoir si le chef du parti
conservateur des modérés ou le fuck rite
personnes qu'on est ici à l'image qui
semble disposer d'une légère avance
insolente svenska dagbladet sera en
mesure de former un nouveau gouvernement
et donc de succéder à la
sociale-démocrate mac dan henderson l'un
comme l'autre ont dit vouloir attendre
le résultat final mais quelle que soit
l'issue du scrutin la suède se dirige
vers un nouveau mandat désordonnés
prévient le dagen signataires qui relève
que ni la gauche ni la droite ne
disposera d'une majorité solide à
l'assemblée ce qui ouvre la voie à des
alliances nous conventionnelle je cite y
compris avec évidemment l'extrême droite
un le parti nationaliste anti
immigration d y est mis à kelson dont la
formation enregistrent un nouveau record
pauline avec un score provisoire autour
de
27% l'extrême droite hélène dont des
milliers de partisans ont défilé hier à
belgrade contre la tenue dans la
capitale serbe de l'europride c'est
l'édition européenne de la marche des
fiertés mais le frankfurter allgemeine
zeitung rapporte que ces manifestants
auxquels se sont joints de nombreux
représentants de l'église orthodoxe
serbe ont défilé en brandissant des
icônes des drapeaux religieux et des
croix et promis d'organiser une
contre-manifestation si les
organisateurs de l'europride
maintiennent leur projet de défiler
samedi prochain
de son côté le président serbe
aleksandar vucic a fait savoir que la
police annoncera demain si cette grande
marche des fiertés européenne est
autorisé ou non et puis au royaume-uni
enfin le cercueil d'elizabeth ii est
donc arrivé hier à édimbourg en écosse
où une cérémonie religieuse doit avoir
lieu aujourd'hui et le dernier voyage de
la reine elizabeth ii fait bien sûr
toujours la une de la presse britannique
qui évoque le voyage le plus triste de
la souveraine et le longueur voir des
britanniques elizabeth 2 l'ultime ultime
périple j'en perds mon latin de l'amf
est également pauline la une du parisien
aujourd'hui en france qui s'est demandé
eh bien pourquoi beaucoup de français
semble se passionner pour elizabeth ii
en particulier la monarchie britannique
en général interrogé par le journal
philippe chassaigne qui est un historien
de la grande bretagne explique cet
intérêt à voir cette ferveur chez
certains par les liens entretenus
pendant des décennies par elizabeth ii
avec la france un pays dont l apprécier
particulièrement paraît-il la qualité de
vie les vins et les haras de normandie
il faudra voir si les français
nourrissent le même intérêt pour charles
iii ajoute cet historien le nouveau
monarque en tout cas pauline suscite
celui du figaro visiblement charmé par
sa sensibilité sa justesse la justesse
de ses paroles et de son ton je cite
qualité qu'ils auraient démontré lors de
son premier discours face à des
britanniques rassurer sur son aptitude à
régner avec sagesse compétences et
compassion
citation et bien voila merci beaucoup
aux jeunes c'était la revue de presse à
tout à l'heure dans paris direct